let me give you all a brief introduction
which is almost impossible to our
associate director peter bartlett um
peter's going to give you the wall he's
going to welcome you all
in addition to his role at the institute
where he oversees all of programming
and all of those technical bits peter is
also professor of computer science and
statistics
here at uc berkeley he's also the
director of two nsf-funded initiatives
the foundations of data science
institute and the collaboration on the
theoretical foundations of deep learning
so
pretty impressive so without further ado
i'd like to introduce peter to give us
the welcome
go ahead peter thanks very much amy it's
the intro um so
a big big welcome everyone to the simons
institute uh so as amy says i'm the
associate director um i'm joined today
by our senior senior scientist prasad
raghavendra who's going to be the mc for
this event
along with lots of staff members
including drew mason kelani penland
william hum mckee
and of course amy ambrose i'm sure there
are many others uh and we'd all like to
welcome you to our seventh annual
industry day
um
and we'd also like to thank you for uh
joining us today and and thank you for
your participation in the life of the
simon's institute whether that's as an
industry partner a program organizer or
a scientific collaborator or a research
fellow
so
the mission
of the simons institute is to provide a
collaborative platform for research in
the theory of computing
and adjoining fields and we host diverse
populations of scientists engineers and
mathematicians and experts in other
fields
including social sciences economics and
the law
and we aim to facilitate research that's
profound revolutionary and relevant
and that's possible thanks to community
members like you so we're very grateful
um we've got a short schedule today
so i won't won't speak for long i just
want to close with two bits of very good
news um as
amy alluded to um thanks to generous
grants from the simon's foundation the
nsf and also uh the doe we've added um
three new cohorts of post docs to the
institute
community
in addition to the research fellows that
we've had you know every semester for
our for our
collaborative programs
we now host simon's berkeley
postdoctoral researchers quantum
postdoctoral researchers and machine
learning postdoctoral researchers for
periods of one to two years so that's
increased our population of postdoctoral
level uh folks over the course of the
year from the typical 30 to 35
up to 54 so an increase of around
two-thirds from from the previous year
at any rate uh and and we're um happy to
facilitate introductions
among our community so contact amy if
you want help on that
and the second piece of good news is the
institute's recently welcomed paypal as
a new industrial partner
ignacio de lozaga will be introducing
paypal's
work in ai and blockchain
later today so about that schedule we're
going to hear talks by
ignacio and
other representatives of our industry
partners we're going to hear from our
research fellows in our two current
programs so that's computational
complexity of statistical inference and
geometric methods in optimization and
sampling and we're going to hear from
the scientific organizers of these
programs and from several of our future
programs so there's going to be quite a
quite a lot of information in a
short window of time if you miss
anything you'll find most of the content
on our youtube channel so
you can always go there and and check it
out so we hope it's informative we hope
it's enjoyable
do take part in the informal networking
in in gather town
you know we've seen that those those
connections can be really fantastic
um and let me thank the
the dedicated staff that that made this
uh made this possible they've really
worked tirelessly for it so big thank
you to them
all right so i'd like to uh um
uh introduce the mc for today senior
scientist prasad bragavendra um who's uh
also professor of uh computer science
electrical engineering here at berkeley
over to you
prasad thanks peter uh welcome everyone
to the seventh annual industry day i
hope you had a
chance to review the logistics
information in the booklet that we sent
yesterday uh let me share today's agenda
yeah so first we have
we'll hear from our industry partners
each talk will be
five minutes with one minute for
questions uh we then have a 30 minute
networking break on gather town uh this
space setup as amy said with tables for
each industry partner and we hope all of
you can drop in i will then hear
lightning talks from our fellows um
about ten of them and finally several
program organizers will provide
overviews of the current programs and
two upcoming programs and two programs
with extended reunions next summer
so uh let's
without
further ado
uh let's uh i'd like to introduce uh tal
robin from algorand and we'll be giving
the first talk today
hi
thank you i'm always excited to be part
of anything simon's related i love this
place i think the work that you're doing
is just unbelievable
and uh who knows uh hopefully to be back
there in person sometimes in the near
future
okay
so i i i didn't know exactly what the
audience would be like so i did some um
a talk which is sort of a mix of things
let's see what i get through and uh
uh
we'll we'll go from there
am i in presentation mode